what's going on there reject nation we
are here with episode two of hawkeye if
you saw episode one reaction you know
how this goes hit that like button yeah
that's all we really ask for right now
you can hit the dislike button that's
gonna go away soon haha subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction for
hawkeye is up thank you for koi zhandra
for being here follow him on his youtube
channel he is our comics expert he's the
guy to just keep pointing out things
obnoxiously and be like okay i get that
happening in the comics corey but can we
just enjoy the show
hey check us out here we got full length
watch long extra hot guy sync up with
the time code over there we covered much
shows with the same tier you get the
astral reaction highlights and watch
alongs included lastly thank you to the
boys at prepper for editing all these
highlights don't expect corey to be here
for every marvel show we cover or maybe
not pressure him into telling him
since we agreed you're disagreeing with
get us in over our heads people
[Music]
so that that's how you operate you're
just constantly looking for things that
are suspicious or weird
[Laughter]
um you know some some people have
actually called me the world's greatest
archer
yeah are you one of those people
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice place for a kid yeah i oh cool
we didn't see that last time
get that vest off so i can get going
yeah
yeah i'll be right there
so uh now that i've answered all your
questions i have so many for you uh
starting with
can you sign this oh
you're kind of my favorite avenger are
you okay by the way i'm good oh yeah no
oh i'm fine you should see the other
guys i did track suit mafia that's their
name that's a little on the nose don't
you think
no way you're connected to the suit
whatsoever that's right i need you to be
sure i am certain yes
the traxxas must have followed you from
the auction to where i found you
did you stop anywhere before that i just
dropped off the dog
oh [ __ ]
and my name's on the buzzer
[Laughter]
i like this episode
in this might release two
[Music]
[Music]
leave it go back for it
[Music]
if it's not melted it's going to be fine
it's fireproof maybe yeah probably where
are we going
getting further away from those people
trying to kill you
delete sarporos oh
we need some supplies
hell yeah
avengers supplies
[Music]
[Laughter]
look i gotta find a place to stash you
safe so i'm gonna cover this suit and
clean your mess stash me not a pack of
money
no you're not
that can learn to be useful to me
[Laughter]
so many easter eggs oh yeah i'm just
like scanning scanning
yes hey uh hi yeah we're i got pizza
pizza
uh-huh um yep
[Music]
i think the track suits would have a lot
of enemies for stealing from that
auction
yeah if that comes into play
[Music]
hey hey that was crazy an explosion some
kind of black market auction i know
nothing about anything like that
was this
oh i i started to describe um
what i could remember of the tracksuits
faces
very warm
[Laughter]
when you guys land your mom's gonna be
waiting for you there okay is this about
the ninja no it's not about the ninja
most important things remember these
three words don't lose nate the worst
[Laughter]
he really loves his family
you're gonna kill that dog
[Music]
the mouse
no no it's just so i can hear you
and to be clear knox i want you just
cause i need you oh
what happened
[Laughter]
hard to tell
me a superhero
wow stevie you want to say hi
[Music]
hey look that one's you no it's katniss
everdeen let's go
you know uh if all goes as planned today
kate this is probably gonna be the last
time we see each other
sure
here put your phone number in here for
emergencies only
just letting it ring through so i have
got you
emergencies only or i'll block and
delete you
[Laughter]
merry christmas all right okay cool
call you later no please don't
[Laughter]
they do work really well together
incredibly yeah what are you wearing
oh this uh it's um a friend's i gotta
i'm just buying what's this i hear about
a fire in your apartment last night i
can explain it can we talk
without the interloper
she likely feels displaced by me and
she's testing our new dynamic
wow
she feels threatened by me and you know
what i can understand why i bought a
book about being a step dad
[Music]
oh he's going to get the classic hawkeye
suit is that about to happen ah
what was your question gotta blend in
somehow i'm not trying to cause any
trouble here i just want to talk to that
guy that ninja right there stole that
suit
when is it over midnight
yeah that's not gonna work it's just
gonna take a couple ah hey
[Laughter]
most of those folks out there are uh
firefighters and cops
and if you break the rules
it's gonna get real messy
what are the rules
time to play
okay
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
no dice i was i went i got excited
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is wonderfully inspired
[Laughter]
aren't you hawkeye look i'm not trying
to cause a scene here all right out of
respect
wherever the hell this is but i'm plumb
out of patience so you got two choices
you understand i could take this pretend
sword
and i take that suit
where i'm going to reel punch you
[Laughter]
just let me kill you
i'll give you the suit
no
this is as close as i'm ever gonna get
to being one
huh just work with me let me kill you
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
winner takes the suit
[Music]
clingy
[Music]
i could call you clint yeah
you could also take this to the front
desk
yeah can't have that show up on my
credit card no they will charge
you did have fun right
glad i did it
[Music]
yes you are
stay careful oh yeah uh i'm i'm grills
nice to meet you girls grills who is
that boy yeah the guy from the apartment
complex that befriends him and convinces
him to make the good decisions later in
the second arc oh yeah i don't want to
give anything away have you got what i'm
saying
i was a two-time state champion
good with all the outdated weapons i'd
say it made me pretty aware of when
someone is trying to stab you in the
back
common interest is
very fertile ground for bonding
that's exactly what i was thinking
what do you say we break out a couple of
these bad boys just say let's fight yes
i'm gonna go get my stuff
[Music]
go get my ronin sword
[Laughter]
[Music]
she didn't even digest your food yet i'm
gonna get a cramp i know
no this is two hours later oh okay
[Music]
what are you hiding jack
nothing
i'm an open book
right darling
okay why don't you start by
apologizing jack
sorry for scaring you into telling the
truth
[Music]
what is coach
you're going
[Music]
go guys
[Music]
you know sometimes back-to-back calls
isn't the right move in this case it was
i'm sorry
clint barton can't take your call right
now
quasi oh
damn
great high-tech ass phone bishop
security the best man i mean everybody
knows it
the law doesn't apply
a nice place she got here
because it was getting very hard to find
place now all the warehouses are being
converted into loft so how can i get
something better
kate bishop
not key bishop keep bishop this guy bro
bishop is not guy
wow
can i speak to your manager
[Music]
i mean is that him there i would really
like to speak to your boss
look at me okay because i'm
interrogating you right now bro
you're the shift manager where is it
i've never met her i have no idea oh
[ __ ] should go farther
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro i found her
oh wow didn't i didn't realize we're
supposed to spring guns
don't worry
oh is it echo it's gotta be i think it's
her yeah it's here
[Music]
looks like daredevil lighting mm-hmm
which she ties into as well nicely yeah
i like that one more the episode yep
i liked it way more that was way better
i see why it's a pair yeah for a
cliffhanger of everyone going who is
that
for a whole bunch of youtube channels to
ruin it for everyone yeah
immediately
[Laughter]
all right well i that felt long as hell
i feel like we've been sitting here for
like an hour and a half
no not i don't mean that in a bad way
substantially yeah felt substantial and
thick
everything we were saying in the episode
one like the first 10 minutes i was like
yeah this is already making all of
episode one a lot better right here yeah
it's really a two-parter and i think the
second half is much more the comic
because it needs to be that like one-two
punch the pair of them and orders are
always tricky and i i love where the
second episode went like that was much
more what i was hoping for much more
what i was thought before i think their
chemistry together is really solid and
i'm loving jeremy renner's performance
just like he's so dejected with everyone
that he's around by but when he talks
with his family he actually looks seems
happy yeah you know like that's his
motivation and they make that so clear
just in the way the the dialogue
exchanges go it's like yes i made it
really utterly clear with i got five
days to get back to my family for
christmas yeah i'm gonna be that ticking
clock very clear but i love his
performance in this you do see a lot
more of that reflection from the matt
fraction run in here more than you did
in any of the movies you start off here
when jeremy renner's helping kate um you
know heal up and stuff she just sees him
in this heroic avengers light yeah you
know the oh my god autograph my bow
autograph my bow where are we going to
hide out are they cool who are we going
to contact and then they're just at a
store so slowly this
hawkeye starts to go away she starts to
be more herself too and like starts to
equip at him and make fun of him and
stuff and break him down and you're
slowly starting to see like these little
exchanges because when he helped her fix
the wound it was an interesting scene to
have so much focus on it but it's like
kind of working on multiple layers here
because she doesn't understand a lot of
this vigilante work he's helping her out
this is teasing of the mentor student uh
dynamic but also she doesn't have a
father and this is like a father figure
like she has her stepdad at home who she
does not like and is very antagonistic
towards this guy you know clint is going
to serve as like a father figure for her
in a lot of ways but you know before i
just monologue here forever genre yeah i
agree i thought this built really
wonderfully on the first one and they
complement each other really well in
that the first one is much more kate's
episode this is much more clint's
episode and then by the end they're
maneuvered into the exact same sort of
predicament what feels like fully now
the adventure is off so yeah it's like
act one is
in full swing like what you guys were
talking about the previous review i i
love how they do imbue all of the
you know it's like the music has all
these christmasy flourishes and there's
all this christmasy atmosphere and it's
an interesting again backdrop but it
does feel like it's
actually plugged in to the show which
which heightens a certain element of
just the interpersonal uh relationships
and for as much as yeah there's that
warmth with clint towards his family i'm
excited to see him and kate build
something familial over the course of
this season of that kind of spirit which
is just kind of
just a weird little sidebar i noted but
but yeah i thought this was really
thrilling and i mean the tracksuit mafia
is very very fun in the way they
realized them i thought this was really
fun it's interesting the way they draw
the tension here and i'm really curious
to see what you got to say normally with
these shows there's like a
like there's a very obvious external
threat that we're building towards and
here i don't really feel much tension or
stakes around that it's more like ah
[ __ ] she got wound up in a couple of
things and the tracksuits his mafias
after her because uh she they thought
she's roman and i was like okay all
right but the real tension
is coming from whatever the hell is
happening with
jack and what's what's kate's mom's name
eleanor
eleanor fear from i go rare for micah
and uh
swordsman swordsman jack they call him
jack here it's like what is it in the
comics wacky yeah but the jack makes
sense yeah makes sense yeah it's
everything that's going on there the
real tension among that but admittedly
i'm not too interested in they have a
mystery around here i'm not really like
itching to find out the mystery to be
honest
it's kind of just obvious what the
mystery is at the moment i feel like the
the very obvious like swordsman mislead
is that it's her and therefore we're
going to be like well it was her but
they've done a really good job always
subverting not always but mostly
supporting expectations for me where
they manipulate comic book fan
explanations and expectations the
excitement of my first episode with
grill was that's a character from the
comic book that befriends hawkeye
because he lives in the building and the
comic book hawkeye buys the whole
building and like that's a totally
different dynamic where he's like the
temporary landlord to protect the
building from the tracksuit mafia so the
tracksuit mafia is trying to invade this
neighborhood that's the last bastion of
hope for them so he befriends grill in
that kind of relationship and grill
knows he's hawk guy uh and it's this
really fun danny two of them fat white
guy yeah he's a big fan yeah
and he grills like he's the guy that
grills and he's this really important
character where we meet his dad it
really opens hawkeye up so what i'm
curious about is that scene in this
episode opened hawkeye up because we've
seen him really curmudgeonly with
everyone except his family and then at
the end he gets hawkeye to admit he had
fun so that was in its own way the same
dynamic that grill and hawkeye have
translated into this medium so in the
comic book it's the getting to open up
by taking a trip by having this
adventure and this it's getting to open
up this way so he serves the same
purpose in a completely different way so
i'm also curious what other fraction
characters come into play that serve
their purpose in this new story what do
you guys think about the way this is
shot i don't love the fight sequences
but i do love the narrative like i'm
enjoying the exposition shots where the
show is setting and i feel like the
christmas flavor and i feel new york
really strongly here because i'm a new
york guy and i'm thinking hoping that
leads to a west coast side where this
goes west coast avengers where it goes k
bishop and then we're gonna feel like
the the sunshine of california because
they're really focusing on exposition of
location so i'm enjoying all that and i
enjoy the the red uh comedy edits but
the fight so far i don't love that
they're just like long wides that they
feel kind of a slow pace due to the
distance from the action one thing i
would always feel with especially the
live-action marvel shows so far they
always felt
more like a like a cinematic but for
television and here this i really feel
like i'm watching a tv show for the
first time obviously yeah it very much
feels like a show yes yeah i would agree
with that so there's something kind of
missing in a bit in like the quality of
the execution of how it shot for me and
i don't know if that's just only because
i'm so used to the fact that
when i watched like one division or um
the falcon winter soldier and loki they
felt just so composed in the way they
were done that they felt like it was
captured through a truly cinematic lens
despite whatever opinion you might have
of those shows it i i feel like that was
a really big compliment associated with
those series but this one it does feel a
little bit more like
yeah show yeah
it's a bit workmanlike to me in the way
that it's doing its visuals and i'm
waiting that kind of works in some ways
yeah yeah exactly which i'm wondering
how that ties into like i feel like i
think as much as we enjoyed act one
because of the step up from episode one
to two i think act two is going to draw
more attention we're gonna meet the
villain more that i think the workman
thing is going to actually benefit it
yeah you might have just been stepping
on what you're about to say but like i
feel like that's a benefit of the style
but so far we're all feeling that same
like
it matches a little flat
yeah
it matches the setting in the subjects
but there is something uh maybe
transportive or or there's a little
element of oomph that i still feel like
they could level up on or something like
that because yeah they have these
occasional shots that are really
gorgeous of like here's a big wide touch
of like a big setting to let you drink
in but for the most part uh i i have not
yet been able to pinpoint like the
show's visual style exactly i was
thinking i was thinking that when i was
watching i'm like what is exactly the
style or genre of this
of this series right now i mean it's
there's a lot of funny stuff
that second episode left from i gave the
first episode in that mid season that
second episode was high b's yeah so like
the leap up for me was was pretty
incredible to the point where i think
the second act is going to be fully me
and i think there's a i mean it's
obviously this is why they at least
wanted to at once but i think next week
when we watch the beginning of the
second act it'll be more what we're
going for i think it's one of those
things where i'm like i've been
interested and i was engaged from
beginning to end on this one but when
it's over i'm like
okay yeah
like i i don't find myself rushing to
look at easter eggs or look at
connecting tissue or google or do the
things with the other shows left to
share my thoughts yeah and here i'm
excited to talk with you guys but i
don't feel like and and that's also the
nature of what's tricky about these kind
of shows is one division was a mystery
loki is an expositional pondering of the
world in your own thoughts falcon winter
soldier had like the action twists of a
thriller from the 80s this is the first
one that has a show pacing that like i
don't know what the conversations we
tweak are gonna be
yeah it's and because it's also so
simple than what it's doing especially
comparatively to where we've been
especially yeah comparatively but that's
the thing i love about the comic is is
like what this look i i think i might
have enjoyed the first half of this
episode more than the last half when
it's kate and clint and they're getting
to know each other when they're you know
getting patched up and yeah you're
getting past the sheen of what it means
to be a hero anytime he's like kind of
stressed out about it like all that and
even him interacting in the in the large
play like that uh the larp
yeah
i thought that was great yeah i love the
way they filmed the action there
actually really worked the the slow-mo
like bro of like him just like dealing
with that was was everything i guess
because i still feel like i'm still just
getting to know
kate and her the family stuff that i'm
not as emotionally invested in what like
what's really going on here that that
question what's really going on here i'm
not really that invested in it i'm kind
of just like watching it unfold sure but
i'm not on the edge of my seat or find
it thrilling or tense or something i'm
not bored but i'm not exactly excited
for me that's why it lands in that b
range because i have no giant qualms
that keep it from a bee but there's
nothing that's got me like hey like so
it's this weird i'm invested i'm really
excited for next week i'm really excited
for more but at the same time i do have
like the stakes of the last three shows
were so insane it seems to me too that
this one has more place setting to do
than the previous shows because the
previous shows each one starts out with
like i mean you have clint but we're
just getting to know kate we're just
getting to know a lot of the context
surrounding her life whereas the other
shows our main characters are people we
know pretty well it's a really good
point and so there's less place setting
for loki to do or for one division to do
exactly yeah yeah be like if mobius was
the lead we'd have to have an episode of
and then in this case like kate bishop
is our lead so that's that's that's
really fair and i i keep thinking and
that's just how i think like i'm really
excited for act two because that's where
things shape and i'm also really curious
where like the one of the lead
characters in the hawkeye fraction aha
run is the building that can't be the
situation here that's happening at all
so that's what series yeah that's so
like what's the story because that's
such a foundational part and this is so
clearly inspired by that what replaces
that element like what allows us to feel
that connecting tissue because the
building's the beating heart to me at
the comments i mean that's the sense of
community and these are the people that
hawkeye protects that's the big part of
the comic and here you're like that's
that's what i mean there's some
placements here that i'm a little bit
kind of wondering what the direction of
the show is that's yeah i think i'm
having this
you took out the middle of the comic
there's all of this familiarity what
goes there but even if i hadn't read the
comic i'd be like what is the direction
of this show exactly going to i think
it's really saved a lot by really great
acting tony dalton i think is his name
tony dalton who plays swordsman vera for
mega especially haley steinfeld all that
incredible but there's something about
like i i don't know maybe i'm just
having an off day honestly uh if if it's
something to do with like the rhythm or
energy the pacing i'm not sure what it
is it's not quite cooking with me in
terms of the energy there's a certain
lacking tension because you know already
how you're supposed to be really
suspicious of both vera farmiga and jack
you know that hawkeye and kate bishop
are going to get together so there's
like what is this it's like you said
it's the direction thing i think is you
know a lot of things are happening that
either we know to expect or that we know
to be suspicious of and there's not
really like a fresh new kind of thing to
focus on yet take how this episode ended
we know it's echo because we heard about
echo being cast if we didn't know that
we'd be like
who's that what's going on
that's why
but it's also like but it's not even
exciting like who is that because i
didn't realize this show wasn't really
doing anything of their building up to a
bigger hunt for kate bishop right
there's nothing that hawkeye needs to do
that feels big enough for us to like yes
and kate bishop's already like stuck
yeah it's interesting and it's also with
the fact that they have taken sort of
that reluctant apathetic dejected kind
of approach which i love in the hawkeye
comic but here for clint he is just kind
of like
i don't want to do any of this which i
like because it's funny it's amusing it
reminds me of the comic but at the same
time it also does kind of limit some of
the tension and stakes that happened
it's also really interesting is the
thing i love most about the show is the
thing that can't be in the comic is the
thing i love most about the show is the
family aspect of clint because you
really love him as a family man you love
the phone calls you love how much i love
the moment where she was describing like
what the next plan was as him as a hero
because that shows their dynamic where
she's like the one that's helped him
navigate being a hero that's all the
stuff i love in the comic is a womanizer
and the comic the dejected thing is how
he like kind of she's going through a
divorce and [ __ ] yeah so there's like a
multitude of women that cycle through
and that's one of the big noirish
mysteries which inherently can't be part
of the show because cowboy's very
happily married so that dynamic is also
like the building there's a very central
thing where my brain doesn't know what
the directive is with people not having
read the comic book i'm curious what you
guys are experiencing without that
element that i'm going like but the glue
see i'm trying to i'm trying to judge it
based off of without reading the comic
and i feel like i would feel pretty much
the exact same way it's left up in the
second episode but i also find myself
really wondering how much more it can
leap with the dynamic so far i like it
best when i don't know i feel like we'd
be on the same page here i like it best
when it's just like kate and clint like
like that's the best part of the show so
far katy clinton
when they're hanging out same i'm gonna
leave a weapon guy a christmas and buddy
cops this is everything give me
christmas and buddy cups well i think
when clint starts breaking more of a
sweat and gets more challenged by the
circumstances when kate starts really
rising and finding her own maybe things
will sing a little a little
louder well it's like they have the
death of armand here and i'm like i
don't really give a [ __ ] about anything
that's going on there they haven't
pinned the death of armand on the ronin
in the in the media right they were like
could it be yeah it was implied who's
implied yeah if it was like ronin killed
or if that was like what everyone thinks
right then it would be like now we got
some sticks here yeah kate bishop's been
getting questions is a little bit extra
because she does the police station also
she's not going to be able to get me to
the police station well it's like
everything's a woman on the edge
everything's played with such a
lighthearted tone even the cop calling
her yeah you know it's like and the fact
that that guy after being those costumes
all over tv and the news the ronin's
back and that guy was able to just kind
of waltz around go to the park do some
large social media yeah yeah
like hawkeye found him and the cops
didn't yeah it's doing the thing that a
lot of marvel has been criticized for
which is you're you're kind of
undercutting a lot to let comedy live i
did i did enjoy the conversation about
being cynical though i like to talk
about them being like we want to be
fresh and endearing unlike other things
like i really enjoyed the hawkeyes
talking and oh yeah there was this whole
commentary and like we just want things
to feel sincere and not curmudgeonly
like i enjoyed that dynamic because
that's what the show feels like it's
doing but only at certain levels of
success honestly like cop calling could
have been a real tense moment but it's
just like the way she handles the call
doesn't feel like believable to me at
all how this call would
yeah it's like we'll get back to that
i'm sure it'll be he was just like yeah
you're coming tomorrow
coming tomorrow morning
that's good yeah i'm around it's like
coming tomorrow before work you know i'm
not gonna press you that hard
so yeah you have the cop there and then
you have this whole thing with uh
swordsmen and then you have tracksuit
and echo apparently is all this tying in
some way i feel like there are a lot of
separate puzzle pieces and i can't see
how they all become a connective thread
yet oh wait i'm the kind of guy who
judges a show like this especially like
ones that are supposed to be treated as
a mini-series they'll judge it by how
it's all done in the end of course judge
episodes alone the overall opinion won't
be until the end of the show is done but
yeah right now it's like episode two is
definitely better there's a lot to
appreciate but obviously there's a lot
of qualms that all three of us seem to
yeah that's fine i don't think there's
anything really in disagreement on
surprisingly hey look at us what the
hell hey
we've rebuilt after eternal life
[Laughter]
that's true that's true i know when this
show comes out everyone's going to be
like wow i love my marvel you did it
again you're the best thing in the world
so i'm sorry for all the criticisms be
happy we're just trying to be real
because we get a lot of like you just
love marvel stuff and this is good yeah
so now we're just looking for things to
criticize yeah
angry like hawkeye yeah
we're just dejected
we will make you happy if we criticize
should we hold our
how do we please everyone well don't
don't reveal the curtain too much oh
sorry no
remain true to ourselves guys are you
celibate
hit that like button subscribe click
that notification bell
it's [ __ ] hot as balls i'm sorry for
putting it so it's going to yeah it just
turned 90 degrees today for some reason
it's 92 and what the hell happened it
just turned like that we're watching our
christmas show and it's about my hair
wasn't cooperating so when would be got
to cut my hair i'll see you guys soon oh
michael linden michael i just want to
know how you're doing man you know i i
can imagine it's been a shitty year for
you in so many ways pandemic delay of
disney plus you could finally watch this
show with us on time and of course that
whole fiasco with no time to die just
sucking balls in your eyes i'm so sorry
man how life has been treating you as a
late but you know what here in the
united states of america the u.s of a
it's freaking thanksgiving i don't think
you guys celebrate it because you guys
have nothing to be grateful for young
grateful swedes or switz what is he
again swedish swedish no i think
switzerland
sweden
damn it this has been going on for far
too many years mikhail tell us if you
live in sweden or switzerland give us a
basic breakdown of the differences they
don't celebrate wherever he's at in
jamaica right now okay mikhail i want to
say though that i am thankful for you
you've been an unbelievable sweetheart
to us in more ways than one you german
bastard you
and i've never in my life known someone
to be as kind and as generous as you you
french son of a bee i hope this coming
holiday this christmas season as you're
out there celebrating in ireland that
you have a damn good time getting drunk
all over the united kingdom
yet
weirdo your guatemalans son of a bee
oh you already did a son of a bee
you had all that time to think of
something
[Music]